[Musique]
bien
ça y est nous y sommes
c'est le moment de vérité
il est temps de s'éclater attache ta
ceinture bébés
dorment trooper pas de chasseurs des
yeux aucune menace d'annihilation
galactique
meilleures vacances de
l'été touche à sa fin et chacun va
repartir de son côté ce sont des
vacances détente salut à toi vous êtes
qui vous obi wan kenobi jeu pas savoir
ce que je viens de boire
voilà
c'est pas ce genre de vacances sauf un
peu partout surtout n'oublie pas les
épaules 600 sites des épaules
nul ne sait jamais combien de temps
l'instant présent durera chose que toi
aussi tu vas devoir apprendre à faire
qu'est ce que vous y connaissez vous pas
en vacances
mais ce n'est pas la destination qui
compte
c'est le voyage en lui et demain
ils sont également déclarés seigneur des
seigneurs
voilà comment on fait du dépôt
[Musique]
à qui le tour et c'est de ne pas perdre
une main c'est presque une tradition
familiale
miral amira je dirais rien du tout
et
[Musique]